[Music]
i can't tell the difference
between my eyes
thank you
lost the contact lens
hope you find it
thanks
with a comic book history that spans 47
years origin stories that include murder
revenge and ancient egyptian gods as
well as the main character who is
actually multiple main characters
there's a lot to get into with marvel's
new disney plus series noon night i'm
carlos bustamante and this is et
canada's nerd
[Music]
we'll catch you all
you're bloody useless
stevie steven
you'd be forgiven if you're not that
familiar with moon knight after all he's
not quite as recognizable as say
spider-man or captain america but like
they did with other comic book deep cuts
like guardians of the galaxy and more
recently xiangxi marvel is set to make
moon knight a household name with this
new limited series
hello and welcome to staying awake i
have a sleeping disorder
i can't tell the difference
between my waking life
and dreams
if it's all a complete mystery to you
the recently released trailer gives us a
few breadcrumbs to go on introducing us
to stephen played by oscar isaac who
suffers from a sleep disorder and isn't
quite sure what's real and what's a
dream and this presumably includes his
transformation into a hooded vigilante
complicating matters steven may not be
steven at all
yeah oh my god you're alive what's wrong
with you mark
why did you call me mark
now common sense might say that's just a
wrong number but
we know better than that now if you like
complicated superhero characters then
you'll be right at home with moon knight
as this is a character who in the comics
has no less than three distinct
personalities traditionally it's been
the case that new knight is actually
mark spector an ex-cia agent turned
mercenary was brought back from the
brink of death by the egyptian god of
the moon conju to fight on his behalf as
his avatar on earth mark however is
unique among superheroes and that he has
dissociative identity disorder his other
personalities include a cab driver named
jake lockley a millionaire wall street
investor named steven grant and the
stylish other version of moon knight
known simply as mr knight
though not originally written this way
when he was introduced way back in 1975
mark and his many alter egos have been
away for the comics to explore mental
illness how we perceive reality and the
complicated inner life of a crime
fighter that has regularly teamed up
with the likes of the avengers
this chaos in you
embrace the chaos
so far the trailer has given us a
glimpse of some of those themes as well
as the potential villain dr arthur
harrow played by ethan hawk the show
looks stylish mysterious and if those
behind-the-scenes training videos from
last year are anything to go by the
action will be brutal
now another thing to look forward to is
of course how moon knight will fit into
the greater mcu once the series is done
you know him potentially being an
avenger is cool and all but to a lot of
comics fans the real excitement comes
from him being a member of another super
team the midnight suns
sure you're ready for that mr whitman
even before mahershala ali made his
off-screen mcu debut as blade in
eternals people have been hoping that
this team of heroes who deal in the
supernatural would be coming soon dr
strange wong morbius the punisher ghost
rider iron fist and moonlight as mr
knight have all been members just
give us norman reedus ghost writer
already
anyway that's it are you excited for
this new series uh are you more confused
now than when you click play on this
video and
if you are a long time fan of moon
knight what comics do you hope this
series pulls inspiration from let us
know what you think in the comments
below see you next time